el adn recibe mucha atención por ser
donde se almacena la información y
merece toda esa atención porque si no
tuviéramos adn no habría forma de
mantener esa información que hace que
nosotros seamos nosotros y que hace que
otros organismos sean esos otros
organismos y el adn tiene algunas
propiedades muy interesantes por ejemplo
el adn se replica a sí mismo y vemos eso
a profundidad en algunos otros vídeos si
es que adn produciendo más adn a eso le
llamamos replicación ahora el poder
replicarse a sí mismo no es suficiente
para crear a un organismo para producir
un organismo de alguna forma tienes que
tomar toda esa información en el adn y
producir cosas como moléculas
estructurales enzimas moléculas de
transporte y moléculas de comunicación
las cuales hacen el trabajo del
organismo y el primer paso
de este proceso que por cierto ya lo
vimos en algún vídeo pero el primer paso
es ir del adn al
en el en particular al a rn mensajero y
este proceso se llama transcripción
transcripción y ya hemos visto con mucho
detalle este proceso en algún otro vídeo
y después nos vamos con éste a rn
mensajero a los ribosomas donde el cnt
by por algunos aminoácidos para formar
proteínas entonces partimos del a rn y
hacemos la traducción y esto de la
traducción se hace en conjunto con el
cnt y los aminoácidos así es que vamos a
poner por aquí tenemos el rn mensajero
más el a
n de más aminoácidos
que lo estamos escribiendo de un color
más llamativo porque este es el tema
principal del vídeo pero bueno con el
cnt y los aminoácidos podemos construir
proteínas las cuales están formadas por
cadenas de aminoácidos y son justo las
proteínas las que hacen una muy buena
parte del trabajo del organismo las
proteínas no son otra cosa que cadenas
de aminoácidos aunque bueno algunas
veces son múltiples cadenas de
aminoácidos por ejemplo podríamos tener
aquí un aminoácido con otro aminoácido y
después uno de estos otros aminoácidos y
así nos seguimos así es que tenemos
puras cadenas de aminoácidos y
dependiendo de las propiedades de estos
aminoácidos y la forma que puede llegar
a tomar esta proteína y cómo interactúa
con su ambiente estas proteínas pueden
tener todo tipo de funciones desde
formar parte de tu sistema inmune
podrían ser anticuerpos podrían ser
podrían ser hormonas de comunicación
como la insulina también están
involucradas en la contracción muscular
por ejemplo la actina el amio cine y de
hecho tenemos un fascinante vídeo al
respecto pero bueno las proteínas
también transportan el oxígeno la
hemoglobina es una proteína así es que
por lo menos lo que yo pienso es que las
proteínas hacen mucha parte del trabajo
del organismo el adn contiene toda la
información pero una muy buena parte del
trabajo que hace el organismo lo hacen
las proteínas y como acabamos de decir
los bloques de construcción de las
proteínas son los aminoácidos así es que
nos vamos a enfocar en estos un poquito
por aquí arriba tenemos algunos ejemplos
de unos aminoácidos hay 20 aminoácidos
comunes pero depende de qué organismo
esté observando puede haber algunos
cuantos más
que teóricamente podría haber muchos más
pero en la mayoría de los sistemas
biológicos hay 20 aminoácidos en común
para los cuales el adn tiene su código y
estos que tenemos aquí son dos de ellos
si es que vamos a observar los vamos a
ver que tienen en común estos dos como
podemos ver estos dos tienen en común y
bueno de hecho este también que es como
que la forma general de un aminoácido
pero todos estos tienen un grupo amino
por aquí y de hecho por eso les decimos
a mí no a los aminoácidos que ellas si
es que tenemos un grupo amino por aquí y
aquí tú tal vez puedes decir oye pero
estás diciendo que son amino ácidos
donde quedó la parte de ácido bueno pues
esta parte proviene de este grupo car
box y lo de aquí y por eso le llamamos
ácido no crear porque este grupo car box
y lo es así dick o le gusta donar un
protón y luego por aquí en medio
tenemos un carbono al cual le llamamos
el carbono alfa a este le llamamos el
carbono alfa
y este carbono alfa tiene un enlace con
un grupo am y no tiene otro enlace con
un grupo car box y lo un enlace
covalente con un hidrógeno y ahora aquí
es de donde vienen todas las variaciones
de los distintos aminoácidos por
supuesto hay algunos casos en los que la
diferencia proviene en cómo es este
nitrógeno de aquí pero la mayoría de las
veces la variación entre los aminoácidos
depende de qué es lo que tengamos aquí
en este cuarto enlace covalente con el
carbono alfa por ejemplo aquí en la
serina la cadena lateral es un alcohol y
por ejemplo aquí en la velina tenemos un
hidrocarburo bastante puro aquí tenemos
una cadena lateral de hidrocarburo
generalmente nos referimos a estas
cadenas laterales como una r y estos
grupos r tienen un papel muy importante
a la hora de determinar la forma de la
proteína como interactúan con su medio
ambiente
y qué tipo de cosas pueden hacer ahora
incluso simplemente con estos ejemplos
se puede ver cómo estas cadenas
laterales se pueden comportar de
diferentes formas esta de aquí tiene una
cadena en lateral de alcohol y sabemos
que el oxígeno es súper electro negativo
que le encanta abrazar a todos los
electrones y bueno es increíble todo lo
que uno puede deducir de química e
incluso de biología con la simple
electro negatividad de las moléculas así
es que al oxígeno le encanta abrazar
electrones por lo cual vamos a tener una
carga parcial negativa por aquí el
hidrógeno no es muy electro negativo
sobre todo si lo comparamos con el
oxígeno por lo cual sus electrones van a
estar siendo abrazados por el oxígeno y
vamos a tener una carga parcial positiva
por aquí y entonces aquí tenemos
polaridad y por lo tanto va a ser
hidrofílico al menos esta parte de la
molécula va a poder interactuar y se va
a sentir atraído
por el agua y si comparamos esto con lo
que tenemos por aquí aquí tenemos una
cadena lateral de hidrocarburo que no
tienen nada de polaridad y por lo tanto
va a ser hidrofóbica
pero fóbica así es que cuando empezamos
a hablar de la estructura de las
proteínas y de cómo esta estructura está
influenciada por las cadenas laterales
de sus aminoácidos cómo te puedes
imaginar estas partes de la molécula que
son hidrofóbicas estas partes de la
proteína que tienen cadenas laterales
hidrofóbicas se van a querer ir al
interior de la proteína si estamos en
una solución acuosa mientras que las
hidrofílicas van a querer irse al
exterior y luego también puedes tener
cadenas laterales que son muy estorbosas
y pueden hacer que sea muy difícil
compactar a la molecular y hay otras
cadenas laterales que son muy pequeñas y
bonitas que hacen que todo sea súper
fácil de compactar así es que estas
cosas
realmente ayudan a definir la forma y
bueno vamos a hablar mucho más de esto
cuando estemos hablando acerca de la
estructura mientras tanto podemos
preguntarnos oye y estas cosas cómo se
conectan y también vamos a entrar en
mucho más detalle en algún otro vídeo
pero si por ejemplo tenemos aquí serín
y luego tenemos valina por aquí se
conectan a través de una cosa a la que
le llamamos enlace pep típico y un
péptido es el término para describir a
dos o más aminoácidos conectados
así es que esto de aquí sería un péptido
y bueno este enlace de aquí no es tan
grande vamos a dibujar lo más pequeño
aunque aquí tenemos la serina y por aquí
está la gallina y pueden formar un
enlace peptídicos y este sería el
péptido más pequeño que se puede formar
ok sería un péptido este es un enlace
pep típico y se va formando esta cadena
se vuelve un polipéptido conforme
agregas más y más y más aminoácidos
hasta que se puede formar una proteína o
puede ser una parte de una proteína que
hace todo este tipo de cosas ahora
una cosa más de la que yo quiero hablar
es que estos aminoácidos de aquí los
dibujé como te los vas a encontrar en
cualquier libro de texto sin embargo si
están en una solución que tiene el ph
del cuerpo humano no que el ph adentro
de tu cuerpo ok si tenemos un p h en un
rango entre 7.2 y
7.4 lo que sucede es que este grupo car
box y lo lo más probable es que nos lo
encontremos des protón ado lo más
probable es que ya no tenga a este
hidrógeno de aquí vamos a tener una
mayor concentración de aminoácidos en
los que este grupo car box y lo va a
estar desprotegido así es que en las
condiciones del cuerpo humano lo más
probable es que este oxígeno se haya
quedado con esos dos electrones y ahora
tiene una carga negativa dejó que se
fuera del protón del hidrógeno pero se
quedó con su electrón así es que de este
lado se ve así pero por otro lado por
acá en el grupo a mí no también cuando
tenemos el ph del cuerpo humano es
probable que el nitrógeno se haya
quedado con algún otro protón por ahí ok
el nitrógeno aquí tiene un par de
electrones libres y puede usar ese par
para quedarse con algún otro protón de
hecho si tenemos el ph del cuerpo humano
vamos a encontrar una concentración más
de aminoácidos en los que el nitrógeno
tiene otro protón ok así es que por aquí
vamos a poner que el nitrógeno uso sus
dos y electrones libres para quedarse
con otro protón y por lo tanto ahora
tiene una carga positiva así es que
algunas veces te vas a encontrar a los
aminoácidos descritos de esta forma y de
hecho es una forma más precisa de
describir lo que está pasando en el
cuerpo humano ok lo que te vas a
encontrar en condiciones fisiológicas y
además este tipo de moléculas tienen un
nombre muy interesante estas moléculas
que en total tienen una carga neutra
pero que algunas de sus partes tienen
una carga de esta forma este tipo de
moléculas se llaman su interior
ok sweater jon y sweater en alemán
significa híbrido mientras que la parte
de jong claramente significa que tienen
una carga
si es que tiene cargas híbridas porque
aunque tenga cargas en los extremos la
carga total de la molécula es neutra